we just saw Incredibles - you'll need to
buy the soundtrack now that's its movies
awesome I fucking love this movie
yeah I the trailers really were doing
look like shit
I'm sorry and uh Brad Bird though man
like I'm out of this like dammit that
was really good we want to see a sequel
for years like everyone did and I was
excited cuz I was like 14 years later so
I'm like what up college college it was
a huge turnoff so I went to his movies
still like okay let's give it a chance
let's see and I liked it more than the
first honestly I get feeling it's gonna
be an unpopular opinion I think most
people are gonna have the first more but
I
where's my line I'll just say right off
the bat when I like real fast is that I
even though I like the first film I did
have some issues with in the biggest
issue is that I felt didn't focus enough
on the family I thought focus too much
on him mr. incredible and his midlife
crisis which is fine but yeah it's
definitely not a problem with this no
and but but my thought is that even
though I like the first film I'm like
it's a super family let's see the super
family this one really does there is so
much of the entire family and the budget
show the super family the first one but
I had the table scene and they had the
climax and the rest is him you know and
it's one of those things where it's like
this one everyone feels so equally
distributed like everyone has like a
fair amount of screen time and there I
will say everybody everybody really
plays a part
yeah everything works off of each other
even the damn baby who I didn't really
give a shit about the first film I mean
has some of the funniest scenes in this
high there is a battle between Jack Jack
and a raccoon face it is the most epic
as fuck thing I have seen all year it
puts infinity for his shame like I was
that was the most epic battle I've ever
seen this damn baby versus a raccoon
okay well now we're gonna build us up
way too much I don't care that was
amazing and the animation the animation
on that raccoon was so great because
like the the raccoons like just guarding
a chicken wing or something and like
when the baby takes it I swear
earlier you could just read the look on
this raccoons face and the thought
bubble of the raccoon says this is
happening is this really happening
why cuz if the raccoon gets his ass
kicked like a couple of like gets a
couple punch when he puts up a good
fight yeah like just has this look like
what like is this this can't be right
like it just oh my god it was
brilliantly a ID I mean when we're
laughing our asses off and that's the
expressions in general in this film are
just so good and probably the height is
that raccoon because the raccoon never
says a thing the baby and the baby
doesn't say anything either that's yeah
expressions all expressions and it's
some of the best like it's like Tom and
Jerry levels of like classic slapstick
yeah I haven't seen it god I haven't
seen anything like it like in a long
time like that good like like Travon
with the matera and the babies on fire
[Laughter]
that is well that is what like top notch
Jerry animation that there's one scene
that in my opinion is a little funnier
like this was the x-men in Deadpool see
who I had to really like control myself
to stop laughing oh yeah won't give it
away but it's when they go to a
restaurant and it's reaction of somebody
seeing somebody else and it's
it was no jack-jack versus raccoon it's
this you know both movies have funny
scenes uh yeah this was just funnier to
like everything see everything seems up
- except for one thing which sadly is
our problem with a lot of Disney films
and it's not it's not a huge problem
it's no problem that is the villain
again and we'll kind of go more in like
spoiler corner talking about that but
it's the same thing where it's very
obvious villain is I yeah it's but at
the end like when they discover like the
villains like wow you're good you
figured it out I'm like really because
we all figured it out from about them
know first this character showed up you
know it's so funny because Disney films
have gone from their strengths being you
know the visuals which they still get
down and the villains that used to be
why you go to see a Disney fellas to see
these great villains and it's it's
switch we're now the heroes are a lot
better which is good that's what you
want but the villains have just sucked
hard for a while and it's because they
always have to say them as a surprise
like haha it was this person and it's
really mugs and it's Toyota vation and
the most specialist - no sense
what's so zero sense like that the
motivation for the villain first of um
I'm like no yeah it was no rate no okay
here's the thing and the motivation in
the first film is pathetic and
ridiculous but that's just charming and
we've seen people like that we've seen
fans like that you go on the internet
you see if you like this all the time
and it's one of those things where it's
like it matches you get it and it's part
of the fun - it's part of it because
this one is trying to go more serious
and it just yes like personally it was a
commentary and like creepy fanboy
culture when it becomes not just like a
fan but like the unhealthy obsessive you
kind of have inside the more I think
about it well yeah I was very like the
proto Internet yeah but yeah but this
villain just know it so no because
they're saving it as a surprise I was
thinking that for the climax - the only
part and like sit by no means bad but I
was thinking like you know I remember
the first Incredibles film like you know
the first 2/3 I'm like this is good but
then the last third is great the climax
is wonderful and this one that's release
which were the first 2/3 are just
absolutely wonderful and then we get to
the climax it's it's good you know but
but it's nothing like the climax I just
didn't think the reveal remember in the
first one where it's like we gotta stop
that thing we got take that and there
was a real us versus them
a thing where with this one you get a
little bit in the jet but for the most
part it's just trying to stop this boat
it's like Iron Man and Captain America
fixing the ship it's like well okay I
guess that's neat but it's like this is
the climax man come on I don't know I
thought the climax is fine but but I
think it's good but but then you know
for especially for an incredible
sequence go get let's go stop them let's
let's defeat this person this is what's
wrong as much because the villain was so
weak cuz like and when you say things
like well I like this one better it's
it's hard to judge cuz like and this has
happened multiple times with Brad Bird
films like I heard Ryan came out and I
was like oh that's a good movie you know
Incredibles came out I'm like oh that's
a good movie it's not until years later
and I don't think I'm the only one
because I feel like internet culture
picked up on this but it it's not until
years later that they get this kind of
reputation of like like this is the
Fantastic Four movie we should have
gotten this movie is amazing like I
think honest trailers just did something
recently it's like you don't have a soul
if you don't like this we were it's like
these are masterpieces and I never
thought that at the time when they first
came up I thought they were good and I
the funny thing is I don't disagree with
that assessment now but I feel like this
is another where it's like I might be
too close to even rank it because like
his films just get stuck in your head
there is slow burn and you're just like
at first it's like oh yeah that was good
it's only years later that you're just
like wow that wasn't just good that was
great like I are giant I was like oh
that was good and now I'm just like that
films a masterpiece
Brad burns and projects really thrive I
think when it does come to like sort of
the connections between like
relationships between people
particularly in families you know we
started off with The Simpsons as
no Big Shot Crimea is something where
it's like the family element I think is
where he's just the strongest and I
think that's why I like this one the
most because you really do there was
just so much of that connection you see
them working off each other and it's
funny and it's touching and it's you
know exciting too with all the action I
mean that they really balance things out
very well but the one thing with a lot
of Bradford films even though I'm with
you they stay with you they go in your
mind I always feel like they need one
more rewrite like there's always some
things they're a little clunky about
them where I'm like well this would be a
masterpiece three little I can I can't
think of a single thing I would fix an
Iron Giant there's a couple scenes where
it's just suddenly like wow no no no no
I can just hear the Internet no no but
okay those keyboards are after okay not
really spoilers by me after they see it
like they disguise him and like the
government goes away and then they're
just suddenly playing in the junkyard
it's like we're done and then the guy
kind of turns against him he's a dog
he's a gun it's like but you just you
know we're disguising this guy and like
you were trying you were with him and
now you're against it like nobody was
talking like here we snow and I found
out why because it's a deleted scene
where he actually sees on the TV but
that's a problem but it was there then
if it's a deleted scene in the original
movie Brad Bird do that or did the
studio do that oh I don't know but the
movie it still has like a couple tweaks
that it needs right but but that's why I
don't think that even that that's what I
have you barely kept oh no no I I never
saw that that is not like oh it needs a
rewrite
no does have one scene that was cut no
no no no no I mean there's are scenes
like that Ritchie I didn't have a
problem with ratatouille no no okay but
ratatouille to remember like when he
meets up with you know the family and
it's just like oh hi and they just kind
of talk again and it's not even like a
big thing we were saying like you know
should they pay a little bit more of
like a big connection they're like this
big so it's like hey how you doing he
tried this
it's like you haven't seen this guy
today that's already a long movie and
you will not mind longer no but that's
what I'm saying that there's little
elements like that sometimes they keep
it from being like masterpieces to me
but there seems wrong I'm actually yeah
I feel like if there was one maybe I
would go with The Incredibles like maybe
there's a couple things he could - there
wasn't much an Iron Giant a ratatouille
I would have tweet I mean he's got a
whole lot I would tweak in The
Incredibles either and I this film
there's a couple things I would tweak
mostly the villain but I the family
dynamic like there's just such character
I really felt for everyone everyone yeah
every single EA 10 to 5 every single
character damn baby babies yeah take
that internet that's gonna be like a big
quote somewhere in film I'm just like
cuz I always feel it's like one step
away from babies day out or somethin ya
know whenever we see a baby the movie
it's like oh yeah I was worried that
that was gonna happen in Incredibles one
and it never really did so I feel well I
feel like they're gonna know what to do
but yeah now I got in the action scenes
that's the big difference like I don't
like whether or not this was worth the
14-year weight I don't know but I will
say when it comes to the animation holy
crap yeah they were expressive in the
first one they're way more expressive in
this one the animation is gorgeous the
colors pop it's just I think one of the
first things in this was her hair like
last a girl's hair just because now
they've got the they've had like brave
you know with meridia and the monsters
inc with the hair and that like it's
like it sounds strange but hair
technology when it comes to GI is now
light-years vastly improved from the
original so it's like they frazzle up
her hair when she's riding the bike and
the winds in it and that well here's
everything - cuz Disney has Marvel i
mean they've had tons of experience with
cgi superheroes yeah attacking each
other so they are even more for you put
the CGI
this film was better than some things
like you know Black Panther yeah no
because they don't have to make it look
realistic they can just be imaginative
they just have to make it look good this
looks good I love this this kind of
universe where it's like they always say
Batman the Animated Series is like
Gotham City was what would happen if
like the 1930s and late twenties like if
Art Deco never died and then this movie
it's like what happened if the 1960s
never done yeah this is a future built
entirely on the sixty no it was one of
those things where it's like it was
almost to a fault because in the first
film they definitely had that style but
like people still looked like it kind of
modern-day people where this one's like
people look there's so many fedora hats
and so many like 40 style dresses and
like it it's got like a you know even
like the TV studio it's like it's cool
but it was something where I was like
when you suddenly see like they whip out
this computer screen that's like an
iPhone it's just like oh yeah this is
supposed to be now so but but I'm with
you it's just I it should in Gulf and it
should really like you know totally
embrace it and it does so speaking of 14
years to make do you want to talk about
the intro where it got all weird with
them like I can't tell do you think that
was just with you because we saw this in
IMAX
there's just for the IMAX or are all set
meaning probably for the iMac no baby
yes we got there are words too they want
to have something extra before to make
it work right now it's just weird cuz
what knowing me because it's like so
it's like no Jen they want John Lasseter
I think in anything right now it's it
was Brad Bird like thank you for the
wait and listen man and the next thing
you know it's like Craig T Nelson like
these things take time
I know you've been waiting forever yeah
and then and then and then Holly Hunter
just like so we thank you for your
patience we can it we get we get it you
really want to see this movie in like
Samuel Jackson comes back sucks so sit
your motherfucking ass down and enjoy
the Incredibles to stop complaining
chuckling cranky Nelson's like yeah cuz
I had to read a bunch of lines and we
know you really want to see it I get it
you want to see it so why don't we just
show you the movie well let me talk a
while we took a while so let's let's
let's show you how how we made it with
like here's some scenes of computer
animators doing things ain't that cool
don't you want to see this movie it was
you've weird 14 years and I'm just
sitting here like yes I want to see the
goddamn movie why it was almost like
they were trolling us incredible too
short and that was short film you must
and then there oh my we'll get to that
this boy yeah there's a scene in this
short and I there's a couple scenes in
this short and I'm like it finally
happened Pixar's lost its but not say
I'm just like they liked it was so
bizarre for a second that I thought
basically it was the incredible students
gonna be Samuel Jackson screaming at us
for two hours like this is some weird
postmodern experimental art scene I saw
so we'll get to that at the spoiler
corner but yeah that but I was waiting
for it to justify why was there like
it's gonna segue into so please don't
pirate this move like we're gonna do
piracy kills it nearly yeah that me
that's it that's what I think they're
gonna do but no they're just saying like
we know it took a while sorry
and it's like what was anyone waiting
for that or expecting I wanted handling
career outside of coach if it weren't
for pirates
I wasn't even like thinking about it or
bitching about it in my head until they
brought it up and then I was just like
well if you keep telling me how long we
were waiting for it yeah and now you're
making me wait an extra five minutes and
you're damn well straight I'm gonna
complain about it um so yeah I the
action is wonderful the jokes are
wonderful the characters like you say
you identify with all of
they work wonderfully off each other I
love seeing them interact off each other
uh and you don't they really feel they
really feel like a real yeah and for a
plot that almost feels like a step
backwards cuz literally it takes place
right after the first one and it plot
wise it is a step you know but but the
fact that were just like oh the plots
about giving superheroes to be Lyon yet
what you think that was kind of the
whole point of the first one yeah we're
even right even as big you know well so
we're back to where we started and it's
like I hate that stuff but they make it
so interesting yeah and they just really
really work with it
Brad Damon and like I said all I was
thinking the whole time going into this
was like all I'm gonna be thinking is I
want to see them older you know I just
want to see them grown up and I got over
there probably 10 minutes median I was
just like I love seeing them work off
each other I will warn you now if any of
you are like one of those types that
flashing lights gives you seizures or
something don't see this have that
problem don't bother me and I'm just
like I am getting a migraine like just
webs walk and the villain of this uses
like flashing wine particularly don't
see it in IMAX clip soon but why was it
would you say if that doesn't bother
people uh would you say see you tonight
max I guess the colors are so vibrant
and there's enough sort of big-city shot
and her on the motorcycle and stuff like
that like it's not essential
I enjoyed Deadpool - a lot I don't feel
like I needed to see that an IMAX okay I
feel like yeah that monorail chase is
really cool yeah I think I think I I
don't think you're wasting your money
seeing it a night man yeah but I think
you could also see it on a smaller
screen and still liked it just fine
yeah it's not essential this yet that
way but but it's I it's a very nice way
it's worth the money in the output so
yeah I I greatly enjoyed this I mean the
only problems I have are pretty much
just around the villain and even then
I'm not like very
again this is a classic case of how
really good execution can save just a
blah story and yeah guess if you took
like and literally like the trailer did
nothing for me if you told me this plot
word-for-word I honestly would be like
this just doesn't sound like really 14
years of this guy's yeah seriously but I
did they execute it I di I gotta give it
I I mean well the cast is great too but
and the animators always good but I
gotta give it to Brad Bird there's just
something about it the same thing he did
with the Mission Impossible series which
was one that I just thought well this is
just done and dead not even Brad Bird
can say I'm just like Oh Brad Bird
totally saved it yeah now we're at
Mission Possible twelve Ghost Recon
Protocol rogue nation Tom Cruise hanging
from something no it's Tom Cruise
gritting his teeth and hanging from
which you've never seen me variable yeah
that uh to scrape that dude's got balls
man whatever before it's like I'll still
make them a little bit less one of those
things were it's like dude I ain't
hanging myself out a window or a
helicopter like foot of Tom Cruise but I
also just like dudes got more balls I
have no problem making fun of him but
yeah I don't make fun of him for the
stunts he does cuz I'm just like Jesus
Christ ya know I and off the plane was
still my favorite I'm just like I'm just
like oh that's gotta be CGI effect
reading up I was like no no no they've
really attached him to a play and I'm
like III did there would have been a
long trail of shit flying through the
air if I was hanging off that thing
anyway he has to make a joke so bla bla
bla a really good movie the highly
recommended um yeah I liked it more than
the first again I feel like I'm probably
gonna be a minority on that
to be able to do like it's gonna be like
the first I'm not gonna be able to
really judge this til probably years ago
and I feel like most people won't be
able to either like I'd say five years
so now it's either gonna have the
reputation it's like oh yeah so much
better than first or oh it's pretty good
like it was alright but cuz you just got
to see more of them you got more of the
characters I mean that Bellis I think
the strongest part of the first film was
the characters and this one just gives
you so much more of them working off
each other and I did it good job yeah
yeah strangely enough and maybe it's cuz
the plot to this one I think is a weaker
it's definitely more character-driven
it-- yeah cuz it's not really plot
driven that's set pretty much like
pretty much the first 10-15 minutes in
it's like well here's your plot and yeah
just figure out exactly where it's going
it's not hard
yeah obviously if you were go to like a
sitcom level it's like essentially mr.
mom this is this is a trope I get so
sick I was like the stupid better take
care of the kids visit that it'sit's a
trope I get so sick of they really did
not push that as hard as they could've
and it really was like they weren't
making him look like he's an idiot
no hey we're honestly making it look
like he he is I mean he's got a daughter
who's going into adolescence we've
become invisible was trying the date
he's got a son that he has a problem
that he started with math you know and
then the baby is like the the baby just
what's got a thousand and one
superpowers it's dumbass no you know
it's relatable it's yeah it's that and
this is all stuff I feel like any parent
can look oh yeah the lack of sleep and
the bastard tries he's like work it is
it's like I was like okay this was not a
lazy trope and I thought it was gonna be
based on the drama - oh my god and I'm
just like no like like there's none of
that
it is a legit like I like how he's
trying really hard you know where he's
coming from but you know again I
it's just the dynamic of you know why
the daughter's this way you know why the
father's this way and they just have to
work you talk about like and that's what
makes it work too cuz it's Elastigirl
who gets the job and she's doing it for
her family and it's just I don't know I
feel like you know there's no they're
both parents just trying to do what's
right and to help their family out and
raise their families so there's a role
reversal where she gets the job and he
stays at home and like yeah they learn
things but it's not like woman's like
he's so stupid like you can't even you
know do simple things it's like no you
would being good take care of these
three kids yeah so no very good movie
highly recommended in terms of taking
your kids you can trying as it got dark
yeah it's kind of one though where it's
like there is wind up but there is also
a lot of talking and I'm just sitting
around it's a it is calm or the adult uh
you know of the Pixar films in terms of
like what they do but there is superhero
stuff too and there is a lot of fun but
yeah it's if you can't like the first
one they'll probably like the second one
fine it's it's an older kid movie yeah
this is for ages you know eight through
you know yeah but we saw before
year-olds and they were antsy and
they're talking and they're kind of crap
favorite last a girl like sneaks through
this door and it's dark inside and like
it's like this secret hideout would like
all of these computer screens and stuff
and like this five year old just like
shouts out well done small time so yeah
with you about Eden up feels it earns
the PG rating it's very warranted oh no
I can you know it's not like doesn't get
it's not like super dark without a G
woods they just put in
it gets a little like scary yeah he's a
lot of like characters that get
hypnotized and so they got these weird
kill they still kill off yeah so that
that's it that scene was spooky mmm yeah
who's like us actually awkward
uncomfortable so I'm with us yeah so
again just good job man go see it you
know it was worth the wait I think it's
definitely worth the wait
so that's it we'll see you next time
you